the biden administration cancels
prominent oil and gas leases one
environmentalist said the announcement
was good for the climate which can't
handle new oil and gas development
well let's get to the the nuance here
quote
due to a lack of industry interest in
leasing in the area the department will
not move forward the proposed cook inlet
ocs oil and gasoline sale 258 a
department of interior spokesperson told
fox business however there's also the
department of interior ending two leases
for the gulf of mexico region because of
conflicting court rulings that impacted
work on these proposed lease sales
so
i'm not going to come out here and try
and play some tribal nonsense where it's
like joe biden arbitrarily just
destroyed an oil and gas lease there's
actually questions about whether or not
these these companies
are trying to drill for oil but i wonder
when you get a president like joe biden
who actually shuts down an oil pipeline
at this time how many companies feel
safe investing tons of money in new
infrastructure that joe biden might turn
around and just shudder overnight
without due process just executive order
you're done
why would an oil and gas company want to
go build in alaska when the president
has already shown he will destroy your
investment this is bad leadership
i agree with that actually i i'm not a
huge advocate of burning unlimited
fossil fuel without attempting to recap
recover the carbon but
it seems like maybe this is he's
incentivizing people to get off oil but
it's like just a dumb way to do it like
i'll destroy everything so you stop
using it doesn't make any sense to me
well so you you in in the gulf instance
you've got environmentalists we just had
that story about the the elect
electrical plant shutting down i think
it was called tailin because they said
regulations on climate change so they're
like we're shutting down yo i'll tell
you this you think you think the baby
food shortage is bad
let me just lay it out for everybody
because they're like what did joe biden
do to make the gas prices go up all
these fact checkers are like it's not
true
joe biden bans oil and gas leases on
federal lands speculation goes up
because supply is expected to be
diminished in the u.s
he just shuts down the keystone pipeline
how much money did that cost the oil
industry
a lot and i'm not saying i like the oil
industry guys
then all of a sudden they're like why
aren't they investing to build new new
oil drilling up in alaska
it's their fault we're not getting any
of this stuff done why would anyone want
to invest in the united states energy
production when joe biden is shown he
has complete disdain for it you're going
to lose all your money go go build in
saudi arabia or go build in in cutter
and build that pipeline or whatever yeah
it's basically i mean it's really
childish right i mean there's there's a
reason i'm not generally like this
russia hawk or whatever but russia
literally did fund green energy groups
in the united states to try and push
against domestic oil production which is
kind of an obvious thing to do from
their perspective because hey that gives
them allows them to kind of corner the
market and increases demand for their
natural resources which they're
perfectly happy to draw in whatever way
they want to see fit um and so i think
yeah i mean i was looking at some of the
information i don't know that the
cancellation of these leases was more
about them like giving up on a couple of
like ones that had a con had some
conflicting court rulings about that was
the gulf um and i there was like even
democrats and i think there was like a
dim tim kaine was on giving a speech
about hey we really need to increase
production here i don't know if you guys
are are trying hard enough here in the
administration like
i don't know i feel i feel like we're in
a phase where it's like you've got i
think the white house probably is now
because they're so full bored towards
ukrainian t russia they're like okay
fine we'll let the oil and gas leases
run but maybe the message hasn't
trickled down to the bureaucrats yet
take a look at this
aaa gas prices
441. i guarantee you the biden white
house does not like this right like
they're i like there are a lot of things
they're they're conniving they're
obnoxious but they're not complete
morons so they they do know that you
know gas prices at this level will lead
to them losing power no no i mean you
know the the dudes who are engaged in a
bank heist are not stupid but why would
you assume that they're looking out for
your best interest no they're not right
like th that's i i don't assume that
ever that they're looking for their best
interest i just know we're we're six
months out of an election and the the
joe biden elections
would be like john dillinger like trying
to get appointed as the head of a bank
branch and people being like i never
heard of this guy he sounds great and
we're like please please do not give
this guy i'm telling you he's going to
loot the coffers and they're like i
don't know he looks trustworthy cool
name too and then all of a sudden you
know the bank is failing and you're like
i can't believe this is happening well
joe biden's crooked he's always been
crooked you put a crooked guy in charge
crooked things happen and all these
people are like why is gas higher than
it's ever been yeah they try to play the
game it's not joe biden's fault it is
vladimir putin and the unprecedented
pandemic and it's like dude if joe biden
didn't cancel keystone if he didn't ban
oil and gas leases on federal lands if
they weren't making the moves they're
making now
my my point i'll just summarize it with
this if donald trump was president he
would be like you know he'd be yelling
get me the head of these companies i
want them in here right now what's going
on they're making me look bad we need to
get these prices down and they would
have a meeting you'd hear in the press
that the head the ceos of these
companies are coming to the oval office
donald trump would be like what do we
got to do to get you producing they'd
say these regulations are impeding us
and he'd be like we're getting rid of
them get the oil baby drill and the
prices would be going down
and then they'd be fracking i heard uh
earthquakes have gone up because of
fracking if you look at like oklahoma
earthquakes where there's like no
earthquakes all of a sudden since they
started fracking you see massive amounts
of micro quakes they're not huge but but
that's a good thing of course
earthquakes are always fantastic what's
happening is they're taking liquid out
of the earth and it's leaving like a
crateris vacuum in there and then the
the
the crust just ends up slipping on
itself well they're injecting hydraulic
fluid yeah and they inject weird
chemicals back in i mean uh just look on
the bright side now that we know we're
creating earthquakes maybe we can create
some kind of um earthquake generator a
piezoelectric uh that's right energy
producer we'll get even more energy out
of it right right really ever before you
know turning problems into solutions in
that we are better than what we had at
the beginning is a human thing
that's true i mean it would be funny if
like have you guys ever seen those
flashlights where you you beat them and
they charge yeah
show me that again you beat him oh yeah
i think i know what you're talking about
there they have a magnet in it and
there's a copper coil and when you make
the motion it throws the magnet back and
forth which then generates a current and
will charge up the battery so all you
got to do is is that that's that's not
piezoelectricity
electricity is like molecular vibration
it's free it's friction based energy so
once the earthquake happens you have all
these magnets bouncing up and down
the coils and you're just generating
free energy so after you get the the oil
or i'm sorry the gas the was it shale is
it shale oil actually is it oil
i don't know what happened
the fossil fuels i think so and
everything's crumbling all around you
you just have the electrical generation
and you extract more energy perfectly i
think that's actually a really good idea
we should see if we can do that it's
just probably it's probably gonna take
time you're fracking now yeah wow
it sounds like russian disinformation
yeah but i mean your point earlier about
the uh russian government sending
funding towards certain environmental
groups to try to discourage the
production of oil in the united states
is so depressing and it's just so
indicative of how abysmally easily the
population of the political system is
influenced in this country by people who
understand our way of thinking so
the american government does not really
understand the way russian culture
operates the way russians think think or
the way that the chinese population
thinks but they actually understand the
way we think really really well to the
point where we are extremely easy for
them to manipulate
yes climate change no uh use other
people's oil yes
stop making in your own country yeah
it's like but you're still using the
fossil fuels
you're still using them do they not
cause pollution if they come from russia
it's ridiculous the whole we need to
invade alaska yes
we is
we own it though yeah i'm no i'm kidding
like like we invade it for oil like oh
right
right let it secede and then re-invade
it i don't know
troops and then you know let's liberate
alaska i'm talking about doing that to
california right you let it secede you
re you invade it you occupy it
you turn it into a colony like an old
school territory no electoral votes and
we've solved most of the country's
problems yeah there was there's subjects
there was a fantastic uh there's a
fantastic babylon bee headline a while
ago is biden gives alaska back to russia
so they can drill for oil there now so
we can drill for oil though
i do like that idea of california being
uh it's like oh no they succeeded all
right
take it back
it's ours now right it's like college
you made an interesting point natives
they're called native america they're
native california
oh yeah the uh that people are they're i
think you mentioned that politicians are
easily swayed like our political system
is very easily swayed if you understand
the way people you really need a strong
leader like biden's not as strong he's a
weak-minded older man that seems to be
kind of dis disparate but if you have a
strong mind young person that can also
be dangerous because then they don't
listen you don't want someone that
doesn't listen but you need someone that
isn't swayed by nonsense or or the wind
you know yeah they're a representative
but they still have to have a strong
mind trump was swayed by a lot of
nonsense yeah but well john bolton to
your point ian
you want someone right so you you want
someone ideally who's strong-minded and
has a solid moral compass you don't want
someone who's weak-minded with a solid
moral compass right you don't want
someone who's strong-minded with a poor
moral compass we have someone who's
weak-minded and has a poor moral compass
yeah he i mean he was a plagiarist in
1988 he had to drop out of the
presidential election because he was
found plagiarizing just presidential
campaign just look at biden inc by
politico and they show you this map
showing how
every time he gets appointed to some
position his brother gets rich off of it
he's like oh something like that it's
like how what a coincidence obama puts
him in charge of iraq and then also his
brother's getting contracts in in iraq
i think it's just a good sign that he's
doing you know fortune has smiled upon
him well he's such a good guy no it
makes sense i mean they're brothers
they're both equally talented it's no
surprise that his brother is doing so
well in the exact same areas yeah his
brother was awesome and then i don't
care if he's his brother or not well why
was his brother the first one in the
biden family to attend college is that
true no that was his speech he played he
was like why am i the first biden to
attend college he did he like is
hilarious because it's one thing to
plagiarize a speech as a politician and
take some sort of banal
utterance about freedom or equality or
these things that usually come up in
political speeches he literally took
someone's background story like this
there was a british politician talking
about neil kinnick yeah oh he was like
the first in his family to go to college
and they were working class and biden
literally gives the guys speech with a
couple details changed people like
echoes of biden's 1987 plagiarism
scandal continue to reverberate from
this is uh washington post you mentioned
neil kinnick how is he involved in the
plagiarism scandal well it's that's
that's whose speeches biden plagiarized
right neil kinnick was like a labor uh
he was like a leader of the opposition
in britain right during margaret
thatcher when margaret thatcher was
prime minister and literally kinnick had
just given these speeches as leader and
biden's like that's a really good speech
and it's funny and after he heard biden
plagiarize them he went come on man
[Laughter]
and then joe biden was like
that's a good one that's good we got an
article here from the guardian
of pressure neil kinnick on biden's
plagiarism scandal in quotes and why he
deserves to win quote joe's an honest
guy this is the guy who he plays your
eyes no way that's insane
are we sure biden didn't put those words
in his mouth all the way around for once
better was plagiarized it's september
2020 when that article came out i bet it
was just political propaganda because
the guy hated trump
yeah yeah yeah build back better was
plagiarized and i think it was um
boris johnson called mine i think right
he was like build back better that's our
thing and joe biden started using it
that's hilarious it's amazing yeah
that's just something come on man when i
when i made brexit happen no um
he's hysterical it's sad i and we laugh
at it but at the same time you sort of
have to the reality is this man is
president of the united
the actual sitting president of the
united states the thing is you know he
is not right for that spot because when
you're the vp for two terms you run for
president next that every time that's
very true he was nowhere gone totally
disintegrated and like obama didn't want
him to right that's the thing like obama
sort of settled on biden but like can we
call him an f-up
he just just don't underestimate his
capability to screw things up right yeah
like you don't have to do this joe hold
on though you guys aren't being fair
biden stepped down because he's a humble
man and then when he saw charlottesville
happen he said i need to run for
president that's right that's right
about the fires within i wonder who
actually said that first
yeah that's such a ridiculous
lesser-known democrat who actually said
that and he was like that's pretty good
man it's hysterical
that's so insane like as if joe biden
actually he saw that happening he's like
you know what this is a good opportunity
to make my face it'll be more money it
would actually be really funny if it was
true it would be funny if it really was
like joe biden sitting in his basement
like flick you know flipping channels
and then he sees like cnn and he's like
oh
i have to run for president and then he
like stands up and then he like shuffles
out of his you know with his
in his towel and then his dog tastes
like we have a non-entity as president
right like do you even think no one
thinks he's actually running the country
oh i do like sort of you know sort of
like people i don't think it's his
people i think his geriatric nurse is
making the calls yeah and so it's like
it's it's like one of those old tropes
where the old man's in the bed and like
the nurse is sitting there and she's
like biden says he wants to shut down
oil lisas and they're like well i guess
biden wants it and like pamela walks out
like
well everyone trusts his nurse yeah man
no no who was uh who was who was the
dude who was whispering into the
in lord of the rings worm tongue one
time
for that that happened you know woodrow
wilson was president he had a stroke
when he was negotiating versailles and
his wife basically ran the country for
the remainder of his term wow
so like kamala is basically worm tongue
that was the name
yeah and so by instead they're like
and then she's like he says shut down
the gas leases
whatever you say mr president yeah
and then trump's someone should make the
meme then trump returns the return of
the king oh my goodness do you think
will do you think that there's a
political solution to the the chaos or
you look towards the private sector more
to a political to what chaos having
biden as president because
yeah i mean yes there's a political
solution everybody as president right
kick him out but how can we do you think
that's even politically possible sure i
mean not not in the short term right but
like
you can
i mean you're gonna have democrats in
charge of the white house and therefore
the agencies for the next two years
there's not really any doing anything
about it until you elect a republican
and things get better um
in terms of like a lot of these specific
problems i mean there's no i don't know
i worked for the seasteading institute
you want to have like privately created
like countries or something and compete
compete that way not not nec getting
them out i'm not talking about i'm just
talking about we're in a situation where
we have no leadership i feel like
there's very very little to no
leadership in the country so what what
would be a short-term solution do you
see one politician no there's no
short-term solution to like a lack of
leadership from the white house i mean
they they we're just gonna have to deal
with that like but we're we've got like
two and a half more years of brezhnev or
whatever basically and then you know
we'll have a chance to actually replace
them what's brezhnev brezhnev was like
the soviet leader who was very in a
similar situation to biden where he was
just
very very old very very sick um and
you know there were all these people
talking about how healthy and vigorous
he was in the in pravda
right like that was he was notorious for
you know just like being kind of you
know russia had a really sclerotic
decline at that point the guys who were
running it were all the old
revolutionaries who were now really old
oh well you know any you sort of
mentioned the propaganda arm doing
everything they could to make him sound
as if he was competent and in good
health and they're still doing that with
joe biden even though we see footage of
the man speaking and it's abundantly
clear to anyone who observes it that the
man is not in his right mind he wasn't
in his right mind during the primaries i
when i went to ohio to hang out with my
parents like over christmas last year i
i was like yeah you know joe biden's a
mess and they were like no joe biden's
great and i was like yeah he's
experiencing mental cognitive decline
and they're like
yeah
everyone knows it they're like there's
that yeah you take you just put a video
clip of him speaking 10 years ago right
2012 like with when obama was president
like perfectly articulate clear smooth
smooth cadence i i wouldn't say i mean
more articulate but his gaffes then were
outrageous as well sure but he just
didn't he didn't stumble over his
worries he was he had more energy it
sounded like a normal politician
speaking in a lot of ways right it
doesn't sound like that anymore no
four years out of the spotlight change
he changed drastically in those four
years yeah it's it's um sun downing
is that what it's called when you get
older like you you start losing it your
brains in the afternoon is your up you
know so
here's this guy he he wakes up in the
morning and he's like i'm ready to get
it and then you know within a few hours
we're like turning on a shot at a
pressure
yeah anymore so the argument the media
has tried to make too and i don't hear
this as often because i think even they
realized how ridiculous it was but that
he just has a speech impediment is
something we know quite frequently no i
know well that's ridiculous well i did a
cartoon about this called joe biden's
speech therapist but basically the idea
is like a speech impediment doesn't make
you say poor kids are just as bright and
talented as white kids that's not how
speech impediments work like that's a
gaffe the man says stupid things
tourette's maybe
i i guess but is that a would you
consider that a speech impediment how is
that defined i'm not sure i guess i know
but they would say that he had a stutter
like it was his stutter that would cause
him to say these things dude that's not
how a stutter works yeah it's just a
stutter that just suddenly emerges at 78
years old you know and in addition to
you suddenly just having trouble making
sense yeah people fall for this stuff i
know well and they will they'll
the stutter argument was useful because
what it allowed for them to do was
pretend like there wasn't a problem but
also call you mean for pointing out the
problem so when we acknowledge that
biden can't speak straight in that even
in a state of the union address which
was the best he sounded he sounded
somewhat drunk he was slurring his words
if you point that out people could say
hey that's really mean and disrespectful
to say about the president but it's also
true it's only mean if you acknowledge
that it's true like that's not a mean
thing to say about someone if it isn't
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there